c'est une véritable forteresse culturel
le poumon artistique de saint quentin en
yvelines
inauguré en 1993 cette bâtisse a été
pensé par cet homme stanislas fischer
architecte à l'origine de nombreux
aménagements dans les villes nouvelles
et notamment plusieurs théâtres
nationaux
la juxtaposition d'elle de la technique
technologique sommes d'accord que la
grande rampe
la grande blonde qui est que nous
n'oublions pas une rame qui devrait
servir pour
pouvoir jouer les spectacles sous la
place les postes de statut qu'on a plus
personne
les statuts sont pas arrivés c'est
génial qu'on attende nouveau statut dans
le cadre de la journée nationale de
l'architecturé stanislas fischer est
revenu sur les secrets de la
construction du théâtre national
un bâtiment au coeur de saint quentin en
yvelines il est vraiment pensé pour être
un monument c'est à dire un point de
repère dans la ville quelque chose qui
reste qui est dans la durée et que tout
le monde reconnaît qui marque vraiment
le paysage
c'était adbe pas et moi je vis des mages
de pâles sévère et c'est à ce geste a
fait le bonheur c'était beau des mains
comme ses pulsions
yves estimable - aucune ride à signaler
malgré ses 25 ans le théâtre national a
encore de belles années artistique
devant lui en conservant éternellement
dans ses travées l'adn de stanislas
fischer